on va revenir sur ce fait divers qui a
plus qui a le plus passionné c'est les
Français ces dernières années le 28
octobre 2017 Jonathan Daval alerte la
police sa femme Alexia a disparu pendant
3 mois Jonathan montre le visage d'un
veuf déploré dans les médias il accuse
le beaufrère d'Alexia puis termine par
avouer le pire c'est bien lui qui a tué
sa femme en 2020 Jonathan naval a été
condamné à 25 ans de réclusion
aujourd'hui c'est un nouveau volet de
l'affaire qui s'ouvre nous allons
connaître la date du procès pour
dénonciation calomieuse de Jonathan euh
puisqu'il avait accusé son beau frère
on va faire un petit récap et Martine
Henri donc sa maman et Randal
schwardofer l'excellente avocat de
jeanathan Daval seront avec nous petit
rap et et il faut s V que c'est une
affaire qui vous passionne et c'est vrai
que c'est très très c'était très
important pour nous de les avoir
aujourd'hui surtout avec ces nouveaux
éléments c'est
parti en 2017 la France découvre avec
effroid la terrible affaire d'aval et
cette disparition inquiétante depuis
hier une jogueuse de 29 ans n'est jamais
rentrée à son domicile son mari jonathan
est alors dévasté et pleure sa
disparition devant les caméras était ma
première supportrice mon oxygène mais
alors que l'homme avait finalement été
condamné à 25 ans de réclusion pour
avoir étranglé et brûlé sa compagne il a
pendant un temps accusé son beaufrère
d'avoir tué Alexia il parle maintenant
d'un complot familial il accuse son beau
frère d'en être le meurtrier des
accusations fausses selon la belle
famille qui lui réclame aujourd'hui
plusieurs dizaines de milliers d'euros
de dommage et intérêt alors que s'ouvre
demain un nouveau procès contre Jonathan
Daval pour dénonciation calomnieuse en
prisonn né depuis 6 ans alors nouveau
procès dénonciation calomnieuse vit en
prison les révélations de la mère de
Jonathan Daval dans
TPMP merci Martine Henri Maire de
Jonathan Daval d'être avec nous merci
Randal schwarddorfer avocat Jonathan
Daval d'être avec nous je voudrais dire
juste un petit mot ce livre itinéraire
d'un avocat hors norme excellent voilà
je vous le dis j'ai même je me suis même
dit qu'il faudrait peut-être l'adapter
en en télévision vous voyez ou pas en
émission parce que vraiment 10 affaires
criminelles incroyables vous savez que
je suis passionné par ça et c'est vrai
que ça on devrait l'adapter voilà sur C8
si vous cherchez un producteur j'en
connais un qui peut qui peut essayer de
faire avancer les choses au plus vite
euh merci il est pas là ce soir merci en
tout cas c'est vrai que c'est très bien
bravo merci Martine d'être avec nous
merci c'est la deuxième fois que vous
venez nous voir moi maman de de Jonathan
vous étiez venu nous voir d'ailleurs
pour ce livre à l'époque c'est vrai que
c'était un très très grand moment pour
nous alors aujourd'hui euh enfin est-ce
que votre fils va assister à ce procès
pour dénonciation calom je viens de le
rappeler hein puisqu'il avait à l'époque
il avait dit que c'était il avait accusé
son beau frère d'être le le le coupable
est-ce qu'il est-ce qu'il va y assister
maître non il n'assistera pas d'accord
il pourquoi parce que son avocat le
représente d'accord d'accord vous P
pouvez nous expliquer en quoi consiste
ce nouveau procès maître alors en fait
Jonathan Daval pendant son instruction à
un moment au début a reconnu les faits
qui lui était reproché c'està avir
c'està-dire avoir donné la mort à Alexia
de façon volontaire un homicide et puis
pendant l'instruction il va revenir sur
ses accusations et et et il va accuser
Grégory Guay son beau-fère en disant
mais c'est pas moi c'est mon mon
beau-frère qui a tué Alexia c'est lui
qui l'a étranglé dans le cadre d'un
complot familial avec mon beau-père ma
belle-mère impliquée et puis ma
belle-sœur euh tout cela va durer
pendant plusieurs mois à peu près 6 mois
il va y avoir une confrontation en 2019
et Jonathan Daval va reconnaître qu'il a
menti que il a accusé t parce que il ne
supportait plus d'être pointé du doigt
comme le meurtrier parce que il voulait
aussi retrouver une place au côté de sa
famille qui était meurtri par le fait
que ce soit lui qui a donné la mort à
Alexia il essayait de se dédoiner sur
Grégory Guay ça en juin 2019 on le sait
c'est à quiis au procès à la cour
d'assise Jonathan Daval va présenter ses
excuses publiquement à grégoriger à la
famille d'Alexia aussi de les avoir
accusé de cette façonlà c'était il y a
bientôt 4 ans bien sûr et euh il y a
quelques mois nous avons appris au
travers du journal Le Parisien que
Grégory Guay et la famille d'Alexia cité
à comparaître devant le tribunal
correctionnel de besonçon Jonathan Daval
pour des faits de dénonciation
calomnieuses en demandant une somme de
dommage et intérêt très importante 30000
€ pour grégorigué d'accord et 10000 €
pour chacun des membres de la famille
c'est-à-dire 3 fois 10000 € en totalité
60000 € d'accord euh donc c'est ce qu'il
encourt il encourt quoi s'il est reconnu
coupable de ce nouveau chef d'accusation
la peine encouru c'est 5 ans d'accord
euh sachant qu' il a pris 25 ans de
réclusion criminelle et que
naturellement il y a une confusion entre
une peine prononcée correctionnelle et
la peine criminelle donc en réalité il
est en cours c'est pas le problème de ce
qu'il en cour et c'est pas les enjeux du
procès ce qu'on réclame en réalité en
face c'est de l'argent c'est de l'argent
et les enjeux sont financiers c'est ça
on est d'accord puisque les 5 ans oui
c'est c'est bon 5 ans plus mais bon mais
jamais jamais c'est cumulé c'est jamais
jamais on ne condamnera quelquun à 5 ans
pour une dénonciation quelle mieux on
serait dans l'abération les plus total 5
ans c'est des peines déjà très lourdes
qu'on voit dans certaines affaires
particulièrement graves en correctionnel
alors est-ce que vous avez encore des
des contacts avec Jonathan lavalv j'ai
les contacts avec Jonathan Davel au
travers de de Martine Henri toujours
c'est notre c'est notre lien et c'est
elle qui se fait le relais c'est elle
qui m'a fait savoir qu'il ne voulait pas
venir à son procès parce que il sentait
qu'il y avait une curiosité autour de sa
personne que il ne souhaitait plus
montrer son visage actuellement
publiquement il a beaucoup changé je le
sais et euh il il est quoi il est
comment la prison ça endurci euh ça fait
il a changé les comment maintenant
Martine il s'est endurci il a repris du
poids d'accord il a repris du poids oui
d'accord en prison il est il est comment
là il est bien moi je dirais que il est
bien il c'est il fait sa petite vie
là-bas il a pas le choix puis vous
l'avez vu quand pour la dernière
fois il y a 15 jours 15 jours vous êtes
allé voir il il vous a dit quoi pardon
il vous a dit quoi vous vous dites quoi
quand vous voyz voyez on parle de tout
de l'extérieur surtout c'est quoi en
fait dites-nous alors parce que c'est
vrai que c'est ça qu'on a envie de
savoir c'est vrai que parce que c'est
une nouvelle situation quand même pour
vous Martine c'est une situation à
laquelle vous n'auriez jamais dû penser
être confronté et c'est vrai que quand
vous allez voir votre fils au parloir
vous vous parlez plus du tout bien
entendu de de l'affaire vous parlez de
quoi de tout lui dites comment ça va tu
manges bien tu fais vous lui dites quoi
voilà c'est ça puis ce qu'on a fait les
personnes qu'on a
vu qu vous lu dites voilà ce que vous
avez fait dans semaine voilà tu vous lui
donner des nouvelles de la famille oui
c'est ça il vous dit il vous a dit quoi
lui il vous a dit qu' il faisait quoi en
prison c'est quoi ses activités il fait
quoi ben comme j'ai déjà expliqué dans
le livre ou euh donc ben il travaille
d'accord il travaille il fait du sport
d'accord il vous dit quoi il vous dit
que c'est l'enfer ou bien qu'il est
plutôt non il se plaint pas Mo il se
plain pas du tout non c'est pas une
personne qui qui se plaint janath
ouaisess un centre de détentionù les
détenus les plus lourdement condamnés se
se trouvent concentrés c'est aussi un
centre de détention où en réalité les
gens ont un comportement en général
extrêmement tout à fait remarquable il y
a très peu de de de fait de violence ou
ce genre de choses ça peut paraître
paradoxal vous avez des gens comme Guy
George qui sont condamnés pour pour des
faits extrêmement graves et qui pourtant
se comportent on un comportement tout à
fait remarquable en détention entre les
détenus et y compris avec les agents de
l'administration par derère fois
certains disent qu'il serait devenu amis
avec gu George d'ailleurs làb qui
sererait bah ils s'entendent bien
c'est faut bien qu' toute façon les
détenus faut bien qu'il se parlent entre
eux ils vont parler à qui sinon pu gu
George c'est une
personne pour moi oui mais c'est une
personne c'est un être humain moi je
regarde pas ce qu'il a fait il était il
était en procès pour ce qu'il a fait
vous dites il est puni pour ça il il
piurege de sa peine donc voilà il voilà
vous dites pour vous il il est en train
de purger sa peine donc on on bah oui
donc c'est c'est une personne qui vient
nous dire bonjour qui nous vous l'avez
vu vous bah bien sûr ou il vient nous
dire bonjour il vient vous dire bonjour
donc quand vous allez voir Jonathan et
Jonathan il il vient vous dire bonjour
il vient toujours nous dire bonjour il
nous demande comment on va ça peut
choquer
mais c'est c'est un être humain
justement Martine moi j'ai une question
à vous poser parce que je suis sûr que
c'est dans votre vie tous jour est-ce
que les gens de votre entourage est-ce
que les gens que vous avez côtoyé avant
est-ce qu'il vous parlent plus plus de
ça ou est-ce qu'ils vous en parle plus
du tout ils m'en ont jamais parlé jamais
et les gens est-ce qu'ils ont changé à
avec vous ou pas du tout non comme j'ai
dit dans mon livre les gens n'ont jamais
non je n'ai jamais eu de souci vous ont
jamais jugé vos amis sont restés
toujours près de vous les amis que vous
aviez avant pareil pareil ils ont jamais
jugé non passé ce non non
ouis et et Jonathan quand vous allez
voir il vous demande des des nouvelles
ou de de de de voilà de la famille des
gens qu'il a pas vu depuis longtemps et
cetera il vous dit quoi bah disons que
la famille les voit assz assez souvent
et puis ils viennent beaucoup le voir
aussi pas autant que nous mais ils ont
une place quand même et puis ben ils
nous demande les voisins s'ils vont bien
puis comme les voisins ils nous
demandent tout le temps aussi des
nouvelles de Jonathan et qu'il leur
passe le
bonjour c'est la c'est la la vie comme
ça maintenant vous avez déjà fait la
morale sur ce qu'il a fait ou pas du
tout jamais pourquoi il faire la morale
jamais sur sur sur ce qu'il a fait ou
jamais pourquoi lui faire la morale ce
qui est fait est fait le procès est fait
je on changera rien si même si je lui
fais la morale qu'est-ce que il est trop
tard maintenant vous pensez à à votre
votre ex belle fille parfois ou à sa
famille ou pas du tout bah bien sûr que
si c'était quand même notre belle fille
bien sûr que si c'est j'ai la compassion
pour pour les parents d'Alex
ça vous manque la vie d'avant ou pas ah
ben oui ça manque la vie d'avant sur
votre vie c'est plus du tout notre vie a
changé tout à fait vous allez voir
combien c'est quoi les fréquences de de
vos visites euh on va le voir tous les
15 jours tous les 15 jours vous restez
combien de temps avec lui bah ça dépend
si on a un parloir ou si on a un salon
d'accord la dernière fois vous avvez un
salon tous les weekends on a un salon le
samedi d'accord donc là vous restez avec
quoi 1 heure 3h 3h ah ouais 3h avec lui
ouais et euh pour lui vous sentez que
c'est c'est important pour lui de il de
vous voir de que vous soyez toujours à à
son contact bah bien sûr une personne
que comme tout être humain est enfermé
il a besoin de voir
quelqu'un donc si ça nous ça nous fait
du bien moi j'apprécie et ben lui ça lui
fait du bien aussi ça ça remonte le
moral il vous a plus jamais reparlé de
de l'affaire non on n'en parle pas pas
du tout c'est
vraiment on en reparlera plus tard s'il
le faut non qu'est-ce qu'il vous dit
vous au il vous a regardé lors de vos
passages à la radio à la télé ou pas du
tout non il regarde pas vous regarde pas
je sa même pas sil est au courant j'ai
pas dû lu dire ah ou vous pas dit c'est
vrai ah vous pense sa même pasil est au
cour non je pense pas peut-être que il
aurait vu les bandeaux passés mais non
parce que pourquoi le tracasser vous lu
avez donné votre livre bien sûr ce qu'il
vous a dit il l'a pas encore ouvert non
ah ouais pas encore ouis parce qu'il
veut pas se replonger là-dedans oui
c'est ça c'est ça c'est très compliqué
effectivement c'est très compliqué ce
qui est aussi intéressant dans les
questions que vous posez c'est la place
de Martine Henri par rapport à tout ça
parce qu'il faut bien que chacun
comprenne que que que Martine Henri est
la mère d'un criminel ouis Martine Henri
n'a tué personne Martine Henry n'a pas
élevé plusieurs enfants pour qu'il
finissent dans une cour d'assise et et
que du jour au lendemain c'est le
témoignage de de son livre qui est
bouleversant du jour au lendemain on lui
dit Madame votre fils est un criminel
votre fils a tué votre belle fille et la
vie bascule et comment on vit avec ça
bien sûr on pense toujours aux victimes
mais et là on a on a voulu parce que on
a voulu penser un petit peu différemment
en disant c'est tout à fait normal de
toujours penser aux victimes mais est-ce
que la la famille d'un criminel n'est
pas elle même victime quelque part
est-ce que la famille d'un criminel qui
n'a rien fait qui ne participe pas au
processus criminel qui n'a tué personne
ne subit pas elle-même une multitude de
violences sociales au quotidien au au
travers du geste de ce criminel
c'estàdire que Jonathan qui est son
enfant qu'elle protège qu'elle
accompagne a fait deux familles de
victimes la famille d'Alexia et sa
propre famille et tout ça est très
difficile très difficile à vivre ce
témoignage cétait juste pour parler
aussi à des gens qui sont dans cette
situation là et Dieu sait qu'il y en a
et pour essayer de savoir comment à peu
près la vivre et c'est terrible
difficile à vivre c'est une c'est une
aventure c'est une expérience humaine
extrêmement douloureuse comme
l'expérience humaine de perdre un enfant
de T condition est un parcours
horriblement douloureux alors il y a
plus de témoignage dans ce sens le
témoignage de Martine Henry est beaucoup
plus singulier mais je trouve qu'il est
extrêmement précieux est-ce que après
vos après vos passages en télé ou en
radio vous avez eu des des commentaires
qui vous ont blessé ou des des je
regarde pas les commentaires vous
regardez rien non ai regardé un peu
et là où vous habitez personne vous en
parle derrière vent pardon dans votre
village tout ça là où vous habitez et
cetera personne vous en parle non
personne non non c'est faut vraiment non
on continue ils nous nous disent bonjour
on parle vous avez toujours une VI
sociale comme disait
maîtrefer il y a un instant vous avez
toujours une vie sociale ou plus du tout
si B si av des gens qui viennent chez
vous vous avez des ah bah bien sûr la
vie s'arrête pas moi je suis pour rien
dans tout ça c'est ça j'ai
ça peut arriver à tout le monde la
preuve vous vous vous vous avez
conscience que les parents de d'Alexia
peuvent vous en vouloir de de quand il
vous voit en radio ou en télévision ou
avec ce livre est-ce que vous en avez
conscience ou est-ce que vous n'y pensez
même pas si j'en ai conscience mais eux
ils ont fait un livre aussi ils vont il
ils vont sur les plateaux aussi la même
chose et eux ils ont plus leurs filles
mais eu ils ont plus leur filles oui
mais c'est pas parce que ça se passe
comme ça que moi je dois pas continuer
de
vivre moi oui euh oui vous avvez parlé
tout à l'heure de Guy George donc le
tieur en série et violeur qui est
libérable je crois depuis 2020 et qui
pour autant est encore incarcéré euh
donc Jonathan Daval il pourrait être
libre à partir de quand il pourrait
sortir à partir de quand en en réalité
la peine pourrait être confutée dans 7
ans puisqu'il n'a pas eu de période de
sûreté spéciale d'accord et donc à
partir de ce moment-là effectivement il
pourrait être conditionnable si c'est
c'est le sens de de votre question c'est
ça éligible à un aménagement de peine
d'ici 7 ans donc en 2030 globalement il
pourrait être en liberté exactement mais
euh c'est ça il y a des conditions très
strries ça fait plus de 6 ans que votre
fils est est en prison Martine euh
est-ce qu'il vous lui demande est-ce qui
vous demande de lui apporter des des
choses en particulier interdit interdit
rien ah ben en prison maison centrale
votre livre quand même votre livre oui
parce que
les on a le droit d'emmener des livres
euh des habits des des enfin des choses
alim pas alimentaire tout ce qui est
alimentaire c'est interdit alors il
l'année dernière il y a des journalistes
qui avaient annoncé que votre fils
aurait trouvé l'amour en prison vous
êtes au cour vous avez dit que c'était
une énorme bêtise ça ce que vous aviez
dit la dernière fois non oui ouis c'est
ben c'est de toute façon il il fait ce
qu'il veut il fait ce qu'il veut s'il
veut être avec un homme ou une femme
c'est son problème je vous en parle pas
bah c'est pas vrai donc on en a parlé
mais on en parle plus d'accord vous lui
avez demandé quand même ah bah bien sûr
d'ord oui on en a parlé dit si si des
fois c'est vrai
dis-moi-le jugera pas on t'accepte bien
sûr formableaccepte comme ça non c'est
pas vrai vous l'aimez vous l'aimez votre
fil bah c'est normal que M enfant mais
vous c'est vrai que c'est on sent quand
même un
amour incroyable pour votre fils quand
vous avez appris voilà ce qu'il avait
fait quand il vous êtes dit
quoi la première vousous êtes dit quoi
ben c'est pas lui j'ai jamais accepté
jamais accepté j'ai accepté maintenant
si maintenant je peux dire je suis la
MAN d'un criminel d'cord maintenant vous
arrivez à avanc vous arrivez à le dire
avant vous n'arrivez pas à le dire vous
n'arrivez pas non av avant non non
j'étais pas dans cet esprit là du tout
merci Martine Henri d'avoir été avec
nous moi maman de Jonathan c'est
toujours très intéressant de de de
discuter avec vous et avec avec Randal
schwardorfer d'un avocat hors norme 10
affaires criminelles incroyables avec
Frank Spengler ça très très fort
vraiment je vous le dis les deux et le
témoignage de Martine aussi merci
d'avoir été avec nous venez nous voir
quand vous voulez merci beaucoup à tout
de suite